es algo que muchos esperan con anhelo la
reapertura de la frontera y la
reactivación del comercio entre colombia
y venezuela una promesa del gobierno
entrante de gustavo petro que llevan
pidiendo desde hace mucho tiempo en
ambos lados de la frontera que estamos
prácticamente a 20 minutos de entrar a
venezuela y pues la verdad sería de suma
importancia y tal vez es vital para
nuestra empresa y tener esa frontera
activa y es que la frontera lleva siete
años cerrada debido a la enemistad entre
las naciones vecinas no obstante el
presidente electo de izquierda gustavo
petro prometió acabar con el bloqueo
normalizar las relaciones entre ambos
países e incluso fomentar el comercio
algo que se espera beneficie la economía
de las dos naciones
hay una complementaria de trabajo de
economía que siempre existe hay una
necesidad y hay productos que aquí se
producen que se necesitan ellas y
producen ellas que se necesitan acá y
hay una cadena binacional es que podrían
complementarse a reestructurarse y
entonces el amor eso que se generen
todos podríamos aportar los 30 países y
que facilitará la vida de los ciudadanos
venezolanos y colombianos después de que
muchos se vieran obligados a trabajar en
la informalidad con el cierre de
fronteras nos han afectado a todo el
mundo entonces pues ahora que esté
abierta que abran las fronteras nos
volvamos a organizar otra vez trabaja
legalmente como nos gusta trabajar y
seguir para adelante ahora a los
afectados sólo les queda esperar ya que
aunque el gobierno asuma el cargo en
agosto todavía no está claro el momento
de la reapertura